.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
2000 ...
Hm, mal schauen.
"Gestern war nun wieder
ein Tag des Schreckens,
des Grauens, der Dunkelheit."
"Ich wollte nicht mehr."
"Die Familie hielt mir
meinen Eigenwillen vor."
"Meine mangelnde Unterordnung
gegenüber Pa."
"Bis die Situation
aufs Ärgste eskalierte."
Die Saseks -
nach aussen eine heile Familie.
Ihr werdet jetzt
meine Königin der Mütter sehen.
* Epische Musik *
Egal,
wo wir sind, geschieht dasselbe:
Sie verneigen sich vor ihr
wie vor einer Königin.
Sie sagen: "Das gibt es nicht.
Das kann nicht wahr sein."
* Applaus *
Auch sie spielt eine zentrale Rolle:
Anni,
die Frau an der Seite von Ivo Sasek.
Wir wurden als Kinder
mit der Bambusrute gezüchtigt.
Von klein auf war körperliche
Züchtigung Teil der Erziehung.
Eine
normal funktionierende OCG-Familie
ist nichts Minderes
als der Himmel auf Erden.
Doch wo ein Himmel, ist die Hölle
meist nicht weit entfernt.
Wir befinden uns hier unten nicht
auf einem Sonntagsspaziergang.
Wir sind hier zusammen.
Wir befinden uns im Krieg.
Ja.
Wie viele Tagebücher sind das?
Ich glaube, etwa 35.
35, 36. Ich habe sie nicht gezählt.
Quasi Ihre ganze Jugend?
Ja, kann man sagen.
So ab acht.
Wir machen uns mit Simon Sasek
auf die Spur seiner Geschichte.
Er ist der Älteste
der elf Sasek-Kinder,
die alle in der
christlich-fundamentalistischen Sekte
ihres Vaters aufwachsen.
In der OCG,
der Organischen Christus-Generation.
Es geht um den Kampf
um die Wahrheit.
der Gesamtgerechtigkeit.
Um den Kampf
des Friedens und der Liebe.
Ich und meine Frau Anni haben
elf Kinder auf die Welt gestellt.
Sie sind unsere Hardliner,
unsere besten Mitarbeiter.
Alles wird von meinen Kindern
gelenkt und geführt.
Er sagte uns immer,
dass wir eigens dafür gezeugt
wurden, um den guten Weg zu gehen.
Wie er den guten Weg versteht.
Der gute Weg war letztendlich
der Weg der OCG, der Weg ...
... der Organisation,
die er aufgebaut hat.
Im ausserrhodischen Walzenhausen
gründet Ivo Sasek Mitte der 80er-
Jahre seine christliche Gemeinschaft.
(Chor)
# In Jesus, da sind mir geborgä.
# Hüt und au morn,
am Tag und in dr Nacht.
# In Jesus, da sind mir geborgä.
# Är hät öis i sinre Hand.
Der Glaube, den wir ausleben,
muss sich praktisch
in unserem Leben niederschlagen,
damit ich eine Kraft habe,
die mich befähigt,
meinen Mann von Herzen zu lieben
und ihm zu dienen.
Und auch, um meine Kinder zu
erziehen und für sie da zu sein.
Die Güte dauert,
solange die Kinder folgen.
"Ihr seid so lange meine Kinder,
wie ihr den guten Weg geht."
"Verlasst ihr ihn,
bin ich nicht mehr euer Vater."
So wurde das klar kommuniziert.
Das hat natürlich
nichts mit bedingungsloser Liebe
oder Vaterliebe zu tun,
wie ich das verstehe.
Ja.
Wir fahren in den Kanton Thurgau,
nach Hauptwil,
und suchen sein Geburtshaus.
Sie sahen nicht ausländisch aus.
Sasek. Schweizer. In zweiter
Generation in der Schweiz.
Ich habe drei Monate
als Baby hier gelebt.
Hat hier alles angefangen?
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Mein Eindruck ist, dass er mit
den allerbesten Absichten anfing.
Um den Menschen zu helfen.
Da wir Christen sind,
hat Gott uns ans Herz gelegt,
ganz konkret ein Ziel zu erreichen.
Das ist eine gesunde Familie
in dieser Zeit,
in der viele denken,
es könne so etwas nicht mehr geben.
Das Problem war ...
Das begann
gegen Ende der 80er-Jahre.
Er vergraulte eigentlich
alle seine damaligen Freunde,
weil er plötzlich
sehr absolut wurde und sagte,
sie müssten sich ihm unterordnen.
Er sei ein Prophet geworden.
Letztendlich entwickelte sich
erst später die Legende,
dass eine Verschwörung
gegen ihn im Gange sei.
Aber seine Freunde zu vergraulen,
hat er ganz allein geschafft.
Ivo Sasek
lebt auch heute noch in Walzenhausen,
im Hauptsitz der
Organischen Christus-Generation, OCG.
Wir fragen mehrmals an bei ihm
um ein Interview.
Ivo Sasek lehnt ab.
Anni und Ivo Sasek
ergänzen sich von Anfang an perfekt:
Sie verkörpert das Reine,
er ist der Prophet.
Sasek, der gelernte Automechaniker,
fühlt sich zu Gott berufen,
besucht eine Bibelschule
und beginnt zu predigen.
Seine Vision einer Königsherrschaft
lässt er schon früh im eigenen Verlag
drucken und verbreiten.
Er wählt den
christlich-fundamentalistischen Weg
und bevorzugt Leute,
die sich unterordnen und ihm dienen.
Maja B. lernt Ivo Sasek
in dieser Zeit kennen.
Sie wird von nun an
ausschliesslich und ehrenamtlich
für seine Sekte arbeiten.
Ich merkte, dass er voll überzeugt
von dem ist, was er tut.
Er war so begeisterungsfähig.
Da bestand
ein freundschaftliches Verhältnis,
keine Hierarchie.
Wir waren eine bunte Truppe,
die zusammengekommen war.
Wir haben vieles
bis alles zusammen besprochen.
Wann ist es gekippt?
Auf einmalwar da nicht mehr
der liebende Gott über einem,
sondern der strenge,
der auch straft.
Das war mir vorher nicht bekannt.
Ich nahm das an, weil er
die Bibelschule gemacht hatte.
Ich dachte, er wisse mehr als ich.
Mein Selbstwert ging
je länger je mehr in den Keller.
Ich hatte wirklich das Gefühl,
ich mache immer wieder alles falsch,
ich sei nicht gut,
ich könne einfach nicht genügen.
Auch ihr späterer Mann
wird ein treuer Anhänger der OCG.
Sie folgen beide dem Wort Saseks.
So zu leben,
als wäre jede Familie eine Kirche.
Das ist das, was Gott will:
jede Familie eine Kirche.
Der Vater ist der Pastor,
die Mutter die Diakonin
und die Kinder sind das Volk.
Maja B.
wird Mutter von sechs Kindern.
Und hat das Vorbild,
die Familie Sasek, stets vor Augen.
War für Sie klar,
dass Sie auch so werden wollten?
Dass Sie es auch so machen möchten?
- Ja.
Mhm.
Simons Familie
ist für viele ein Vorbild
und viele träumen
von dieser heilen Familienwelt.
Wir waren fröhliche Kinder
und lachten immer.
Die Harmonie, die wir
nach aussen trugen, war echt.
Die existierte so.
Aber sie hatte einen Preis.
# Am Mami folge,
wänn ds Mami öppis seit.
Schon früh
tauchen erste Gerüchte auf:
Die Kinder in Ivo Saseks Gemeinschaft
würden verprügelt.
Sasek dementiert.
Doch sein Sohn sagt heute,
er sei von seinem Vater
und seiner Mutter geschlagen worden.
Es gab Kindesmisshandlung.
Es war häusliche Gewalt im Spiel.
Das muss man nicht schönreden,
das ist einfach so.
Waren es Misshandlungen?
Wenn man
unter Kindesmisshandlung versteht,
dass Striemen sichtbar waren,
war es Kindesmisshandlung.
Dann kann man es nicht schönreden.
Ivo Sasek bestreitet bis heute,
jemals Züchtigung
propagiert zu haben -
erst kürzlich wieder auf seinem
eigenen Internetsender Kla.TV.
Ich muss mich wieder
der Entlarvung von Medienlügen
und Lügenmedien widmen.
Wenn Sie mir
in meinen über 2'000 Predigten,
die ich in den letzten 40 Jahren
gehalten habe,
auch nur drei zeigen können,
in denen ich über Kinderzüchtigung,
in dem von Ihnen genannten Sinn
sprach, können wir wieder reden.
Kinderzüchtigung wird in der OCG
mit einer Bambusrute gemacht:
ungefähr 1 cm Durchmesser, 1 m lang.
Drei bis fünf zünftige Streiche.
Das war der Normalfall.
Das war für Sie normal?
- Völlig normal.
Ab welchem Alter
wurden Sie gezüchtigt?
Ja ...
Das war vonklein auf ein Thema
und gehörte zur Erziehung.
Das war Teil unserer Erziehung.
Aber ich kann nicht genau sagen,
wann das begann.
Ich schätze,
so mit zwei Jahren oder so.
"Warum
haben sie ihren Sohn geschlagen?"
Wir fragen Ivo Sasek
und seine Frau Anni schriftlich an.
Beide schweigen dazu.
Kaum jemand weiss
von den Schlägen und der Züchtigung.
Lieber glaubt man
dem Bild der heilen Familie.
Das ist die Grundlage als Ehepaar:
am selben Strick zu ziehen.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht treu bin,
kann ich das später auch nicht sein.
Das hindert mich überall, weil ich
ja im Kleinen nicht treu bin.
Dann kann ich das
auch im Grösseren nicht.
Selbst im Erwachsenenalter
gilt für die Sasek-Kinder:
den Vater bis zur Selbstverleugnung
verteidigen.
Einzig in den Lügenmedien
geht es seit Jahrzehnten
um die Kinderzüchtigung.
In der OCG
ist das überhaupt kein Thema.
Als Ivo Saseks Tochter
erlebe ich all diese Verleumdungen
und aktuell auch jene, die gerade
frisch gebacken werden, hautnah mit.
Schon
als ich ein kleines Mädchen war,
verleumdete dieser
sog. Sektenexperte meinen Vater
und kommt immer wieder
mit derselben erfundenen Geschichte,
dass mein Vater
uns Kinder blutig prügeln würde.
Was für ein Unsinn!
Woher hat er das?
Wenn man von klein auf
mit physischer Gewalt
in der Spur gehalten wird ...
... und Gottes Wille ...
... gleich "gut"
gleich "Eltern" ist,
wenn das eine Gleichung ist,
ist das so tief
in einem einprogrammiert ...
... dass man eigentlich bis
weit ins Erwachsenenleben braucht,
um überhaupt den Mut zu haben,
infrage zu stellen,
was die Eltern sagen.
Die Kinder mit Züchtigung
auf die Spur zu bringen.
Das setzt Mütter unter Druck -
auch Maja B.
Ich machte das aus der Angst heraus,
dass meine Kinder zum Teufel kommen.
Ich wollte sie davor bewahren.
Ich wollte, dass sie folgsam sind.
Wir standen
unter ständiger Beobachtung.
Auch in der Schule.
War etwas,
standen zack die Saseks vor der Türe
oder es kam ein Fax oder ein Anruf:
"Sie hat wieder,
er hat wieder, sie hat wieder ..."
Maja B. kann sich
der Kontrolle kaum entziehen:
Sie wohnt im selben Haus wie Saseks
und wird mit Bibelsprüchen
noch mehr unter Druck gesetzt.
"Wer die Rute schont,
hasst seinen Sohn."
D.h.,
du musst dein Kind davor bewahren,
dass es nicht in die Sünde,
zum Teufel, geht.
Dafür musst du die Rute nutzen.
Um es davor zu bewahren.
Die Hölle ist ein Thema,
das bei uns grosses Gewicht hatte.
Wir hatten Angst vor der Hölle
und haben diese
auch an unsere Kinder weitergegeben.
Und das glaubt man?
- Ja, das glaubt man.
Eine von Maja B.s vier Töchter
ist Hannah.
Sie ist 25 Jahre alt
und alleinerziehende Mutter
eines Siebenjährigen.
Ich war immer eine Rebellin.
Das hatte Konsequenzen.
Es wurde mir mit der Kelle
auf die Finger geschlagen.
Je nachdem wie schlimm es war.
Oder auch
mit einem Stock auf den Po.
Was haben Sie gemacht, um es
zu verdienen, geschlagen zu werden?
Nein sagen war schon megaschlimm.
Dann war klar, was kommt.
Nein sagen ging gar nicht.
Man widersetzt sich den Eltern
nicht, das war ganz klar.
Man streitet sich auch nicht
mit den anderen Geschwistern.
Oder irgendwie ...
Es brauchte nicht viel.
Einfach Dinge, die Kinder machen.
Was passierte dann?
Man wurde gepackt und gezüchtigt.
Wenn man gezüchtigt wurde und immer
noch nicht klein beigegeben hat,
also seine Schuld nicht einsah,
kam man gleich noch einmal dran.
Bis man gebrochen war
und das machte oder sagte,
was sie wollten.
* Pompöse Musik, Applaus *
* Pfiffe *
Anni Sasek
zelebriert die sanfte Mutter.
* Sanfte Musik *
Nur wenige kennen ihre andere Seite.
Ich sei zu weltlich,
sagten sie immer.
Es reichte, wenn jemand sagte:
"Du hattest einen finsteren Blick."
Ich lief anscheinend
immer finster dreinschauend rum.
Das bemängelte Anni auch oft.
Sie rief dann immer an und sagte:
"Hannah hatte beim Treffen
einen finsteren Blick."
Das hiess, der Teufel sei in mir.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Klar, ich lief verschüchtert rum.
Aber ich versuchte dann,
die Schultern zurückzunehmen,
um nicht so finster auszusehen.
Wenn ich sie sah,
riss ich die Augen immer weit auf.
So bescheuert.
Was bedeutete das?
Welche Konsequenzen hatte das?
Ja, dann begannen die Runden
und dann musste man ...
Ich glaube, ich brauche eine Pause.
- Ja.
In einem seiner Spielfilme
zeigt Ivo Sasek
wie eine solche Runde,
eine sog. Bemessung funktioniert.
Er suggeriert,
es gehe dabei ausschliesslich
um Liebe, Frieden und Harmonie.
Ich finde Ramon okay,
auch wenn er so rumläuft.
Davon redet doch hier keiner.
Darum geht es gar nicht.
Oder geht es jemandem darum?
Du, ne,
vergiss das mit den Klamotten.
Wir gehen hier nicht nach
dem Äusseren, sondern dem Herzen.
In der Realität seien solche
Bemessungen jedoch ganz anders:
Der Wille des Einzelnen
solle gebrochen werden.
Wenn ich mir das überlege ...
... war das schon krass.
Immer dieser Scheissdruck.
Dass ich wegen eines Blicks ...
Das ist doch nicht normal.
(Simon) Eigentlich
ist das Ziel der Bemessung,
dass eine persönliche Kapitulation
des Egos ins Kollektiv erfolgt.
Das ist das Ziel, das bei einer
Bemessung erreicht werden soll.
Das man erkennt,
dass seine grösste Verfehlung ist,
ein Egoist zu sein,
eigenwillig zu sein.
Dann wird es dir absolut gutgehen
und du spürst einfach ...
Das ist ein Machtkampf, der tobt.
Siegt das Kollektiv
oder meine Individualität?
Siegt meine eigene Persönlichkeit
oder die Gruppe?
Und die Gruppe hat dort
natürlich eine lange Ausdauer.
Da. Mal schauen.
16, das war 2004.
Das ist ein bisschen früh.
Seinem Tagebuch vertraut Simon Sasek
seine Verzweiflung an.
Zehn Jahre
vor seinem Ausstieg schreibt er:
"Gestern musste ich realisieren,
dass ich
gar kein freier Mensch bin."
"Es gibt für mich keine Möglichkeit,
mein Elternhaus zu verlassen
und mein eigenes Leben zu leben
wie ein freier Mensch, ohne mir
buchstäblich Blutschuld aufzuladen."
Ich war schon damals
in einem Konflikt.
Auszusteigen traut er sich nicht.
Stattdessen
folgt er dem Vater auf Tournee.
Die Show geht weiter.
Das perfekte, harmonische
Familienbild hat Priorität.
Wir leben etwas, das
über der Selbstverwirklichung steht.
Ich bin der Meinung,
dass Selbstverwirklichung
eine Phase ist, die vorbeigeht.
Man könnte es
eine pubertäre Phase nennen.
# Keines von den Geschöpfen
Gottes ist autonom konstruiert.
In dieser engen Lebensführung,
wie wir sie hatten ...
Alles war organisiert.
Man musste
24 Std. am Tag verfügbar sein.
Wenn um 4 Uhr ein Anruf kam,
musste man sofort dastehen.
Simon möchte ausbrechen und wagt es,
ein erstes Mal mit seiner Familie
darüber zu sprechen.
Ich sagte, ich habe Platzangst
und könne nicht mehr so leben.
Aber mein Vater und meine Familie
wollten nicht verstehen,
was ich meinte.
Sie verdrängten das und sagten,
das sei so,
weil ich von dämonischen Mächten
angegriffen werde.
Dann schaukelte sich
die Diskussion immer mehr hoch,
bis sie fanden,
sie müssten den Dämon austreiben,
der mich befallen hat.
Dann wurde
ein echter Exorzismus praktiziert.
Dabei schlug und verprügelte mich
die ganze Familie.
Mit Schlägen,
nicht mit Gegenständen.
Sie wollten
den Teufel aus mir befehlen.
Das war
eine sehr traumatische Erfahrung,
weil ich ja nicht mit meiner Familie
aneinandergeraten wollte.
Es war einfach nicht anders möglich.
Es ist die Liebe zu seiner Frau Mia,
die ihn weiterhin an die OCG bindet.
Die beiden heiraten kurz zuvor.
Mia ist tief verankert
in der Gemeinschaft und er weiss:
Wenn er jetzt geht,
dann wird er sie verlieren.
Darum gab ich nach,
auch meiner Frau zuliebe.
Ich fügte mich in mein Schicksal,
weil ich sah,
dass es keine Alternative,
keinen anderen Weg für mich gab.
Um sein Familienglück zu retten,
spielt er die Rolle des Angepassten.
Ich spielte die Rolle so, dass es
keinen Grund zur Beanstandung gab.
Keinen Grund zu Konflikten.
Wir stritten uns nicht mehr.
Kein einziges Mal.
Hannah bricht vor Simon aus.
Sie ist 16, als sie aussteigt.
Ich wollte schon lange gehen.
Das sagte ich ihm auch, glaubte es
selber aber nicht wirklich.
Aber ich sagte irgendwann,
dass ich aussteigen wolle.
Da gab es ein riesiges Drama.
Riesige Runden, die ganze Nacht.
Bis ich wieder gebrochen war
und blieb.
Dann kam dieser Moment ...
Ich hatte immer sehr schöne,
lange Haare, an denen ich hing.
Die wurden mir
zwanghaft abgeschnitten,
weil ich zu stark in der Welt sei.
Sie wurden mir
zwanghaft abgeschnitten,
unter Schreien und Tränen.
Da wusste ich:
"Das mache ich nicht mehr."
- Wie sind Sie gegangen?
Ich sagte, ich gehe
ans Geburtstagsfest einer Freundin.
Nur mit Mädchen.
Das wurde mir
durch irgendein Wunder erlaubt.
Dann blieb ich einfach bei ihr.
Ich ging nicht mehr nach Hause.
- Was haben Sie mitgenommen?
Einen Rucksack mit ein paar Kleidern
und einem Portemonnaie.
Konnten Sie dortbleiben?
Ich glaube, ich blieb zweiNächte.
Über das Wochenende.
Danach ging ich raus.
Dann war ich so im Nirgendwo.
Draussen.
- Was heisst das?
Wenn ich
nicht bei Freunden schlafen konnte,
übernachtete ich draussen.
Auch in einem Bahnhofs-WC o.ä.
Hat Ihnen niemand geholfen?
Ich hatte gar kein Umfeld.
Ich hatte niemanden,
zu dem ich gehen konnte
und von dem ich wusste,
dass er helfen würde.
Meine ganze Familie
war ja noch drinnen.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
(Maja) Das war sehr schlimm.
Mir kam es so vor,
als würde man mir den Arm abreissen.
Als würde mir etwas abgerissen.
Ich verlor ein Kind.
Und zwar nicht einfach ...
Ich hatte es wirklich verloren.
Ich wusste, dass ich mein Kind
nicht mehr sehen würde,
bis sie in die OCG zurückkam.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Vater im Himmel,
du bist gegenwärtig.
Du bist der sich Ausgestaltende.
Wir rühmen dich als der Herr
über jedes Atom und jedes Molekül.
Wir proklamieren dein Wort,
dass deine Gemeinde,
dein Organismus,
in die volle Mannesreife gelangt.
Ivo Sasek erschafft sich
zunehmend eine eigene Welt.
Die Tragik wächst ungemein,
der Krieg tobt,
aber wo ist die Armee?
OCG-Verbindlichkeit bedeutet darum:
teilhaben an einem Kriegsdienst.
Es wird immer skurriler,
noch unglaubwürdiger
und noch ein Stück verrückter.
Den Ruf Gottes akzeptieren.
Wir wurden
zu einem Kriegsdienst ausgehoben.
Wenn er nicht fachgerecht geführt
wird, ist diese Menschheit tot.
Sie wird geschändet, sie wird
aufs Jämmerlichste ausgerottet,
gequält, vernichtet,
in unaussprechlicher Tragik.
Ivo Sasek verbreitet seine
Botschaften gratis und professionell
über seine DVDs,
Bücher und Spielfilme.
Mit seinen Internetkanälen
kann er sich zusätzlich etablieren
und gewinnt noch mehr Publikum.
Seinen Sohn aber, ihn verliert er.
Ich wusste: Wenn ich
den Schritt in die Freiheit mache,
bedeutet das
einen heftigen Patzer im Reinheft
des Lebenswerks meiner Eltern.
Will ich das in Kauf nehmen?
Ist mir die eigene Freiheit
so viel wichtiger ...
... als das Lebenswerk
meiner Eltern?
Will ich ihnen das zumuten?
Es brauchte Jahre,
bis ich bereit war zu sagen:
"Moment, es geht nicht nur
um meine persönliche Freiheit,
sondern darum,
welchen Idealen ich Vorschub
mit meiner Lebensenergie gebe."
Seinen Ausstieg plant er im Geheimen.
Mit einer Reise nach Australien.
Er weiss:
Damit kann er seine Frau locken.
Den wahren Grund ihrer Reise
muss er ihr verschweigen,
denn sie würde sonst nicht mitgehen.
Niemand wusste oder ahnte,
dass es dazu kommen würde.
Ich plante das
zwei Monate lang minutiös.
Und überraschenderweise
zog ich es dann durch.
Am 29. August 2016.
Er überlistet seine ganze Familie ...
... und täuscht vor,
es gehe nur um einen Urlaub.
Es war Teil meiner Strategie,
meine Frau aus dem Einflussbereich
dieser Sekte herauszubringen.
Möglichst
auf die andere Seite der Erdkugel.
Es war ihr Kindheitstraum,
eine Australienreise zu machen.
Darum
kaufte ich die Australientickets.
Sein Plan geht auf:
Sie landen in Australien.
Für Simon ist klar:
Nach dieser Reise
gibt es kein Zurück in die OCG.
Es bleiben ihm drei Wochen,
seine Frau davon zu überzeugen.
Damals fühlte es sich
nicht als Befreiungsschlag an.
Es war ein Weltuntergang.
Unseres Lebens, von allem,
was wir bis jetzt kannten.
Alles flog in die Luft.
Diese Zeit war sehr strange.
Wir waren
an den schönsten Stränden der Welt -
weisser Sand, türkisfarbenes Wasser,
Delfine sprangen in den Wellen -
und wir hatten die grössten
Ehestreite unserer Geschichte.
Weil dort klar wurde,
dass es kein Zurück gab
und wir definitiv aussteigen werden.
Dass es vorbei ist
mit unserer OCG-Zeit.
Meine Frau realisierte dort, dass
ihr ganzes Leben in Scherben lag.
Mia,
die treu ergebene Schwiegertochter,
versucht zunächst zu verhandeln.
Doch Ivo Sasek
stellt in einem Brief klar:
"Die OCG darf mit keinem Haar mehr
in Berührung mit Simon stehen,
weil mit jeder Berührung
der Sauerteig des Todes,
der Lüge und der Vernichtung
sein Unwesen zu treiben beginnt."
Mia verlässt die OCG
und verliert dadurch ihre Eltern
und ihre drei Geschwister,
die in der OCG bleiben.
Nicht mehr dazuzugehören bedeutet,
alles zu verlieren.
Die beiden müssen alles neu aufbauen:
Mia bildet sich weiter
und arbeitet heute
als Direktionsassistentin.
Simon holt die Matura nach
und studiert heute Recht.
Auch Maja B. trennt sich von der OCG,
vier Jahre nach Hannah.
Ihre vier Töchter
sind alle ausgestiegen.
Die beiden Söhne und ihr Ex-Mann
sind immer noch in der OCG.
Was für sie bleibt,
ist ein grosses Bedauern.
Ich bzw. wir als Ehepaar
haben ihnen vieles kaputt gemacht.
Vielleicht
ist ihnen noch nicht bewusst,
was alles in ihnen gebrochen wurde.
Ich bin schuld an ganz viel Not,
die sie durchmachen.
Das tut mir mega leid.
Das habe ich ihnen gesagt.
Ich habe "um Vergebung" gebeten.
Wir haben darüber gesprochen.
Wir reden immer wieder darüber.
Das ist immer wieder Thema.
(Hannah) Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass es mich wieder so mitnimmt.
Was?
Daran erinnert zu werden,
was alles passiert ist
und wie schlimm es wirklich war.
Das sind Dinge,
die nicht einfach so weggehen.
Ja.
Das Schlimmste ist, dass ich
es nicht rückgängig machen kann.
Wenn ich zurückspulen könnte,
würde ich sie ganz anders erziehen.
In der OCG-Welt gelten Hannah
und ihre Mutter als Aussätzige.
In ihrer Welt sind sie jedoch vereint
und gehen ihre eigenen Wege.
Hannah hat gerade ihre erste
Ausbildung erfolgreich abgeschlossen.
Auch Simon gilt als Aussätziger
und wird zusätzlich
mit einem Fluch belegt.
Ich wurde bei meinem Ausstieg
klar bedroht.
Es wurde mir prognostiziert,
es gehe nur noch bachab mit mir.
Der Fluch würde mich treffen.
Wir und unsere Seelen
wurden ja dem Satan übergeben usw.
Man kann darüber lächeln und denken:
"Macht, was ihr wollt!"
Aber im Herzen
beschäftigt einen das.
Man denkt oft darüber nach,
wie es möglich ist,
dass man in eine
so verschossene Situation reinkommt,
und beim besten Willen
keine Vermittlung mehr findet.
Und keinen Kompromiss.
Die Saseks spielen auch heute noch
das Spiel der heilen Familie.
Wir zeigen
allen Menschen das Geheimnis,
wie man mit einer unbeschreiblichen
Fülle an himmlischer Herrlichkeit
mitfliessen kann.
Wir können selbst über Jahrzehnte
hinweg von keinem Streit berichten.
So viel Frieden,
so viel Kraft und Freude
geht von diesem Lebensstrom aus,
den wir unseren Kindern vermitteln.
Haben Sie das gut verstanden?
Er wird als Nächster aussteigen.
Doch davon mehr im zweiten Teil.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022